olá meu nome é andré freitas vai o da
maneira isso não possui alguma coisa eu
sei mas gemas não tenham gasto ao também
não se sustenta em dinheiro uma máquina
foi o conforto
sou uma pessoa que gosta porque a
oportunidade foi embaixador do google é
um ano passado enquanto estudante e tem
empresa na área web e base que há muito
que falar hoje é porque é que eu adoro e
tem essa paixão em formato desconstruir
o que eu gosto da sala não tudo isso
algumas daniela computador a fazer
soluções de produzir idéias e fazer
projetos
no início me querem ventura passava no
seu laboratório na sua casa há 15 anos
por exemplo do goddar foi o inventor do
douro a combustão do fim de conquistar a
pessoa e eu possuo anos e anos com
falhanços e um réu e saltos mulher que
essa tecnologia fofo que ensina e filhos
da nasa para colocar o nome na loa
superior são os diferentes tipos de
cursos tive jogos miguéis maxwell em
filmar ter neste momento está a presença
de uma qualquer dificuldade em andar um
concurso qualquer de empreendedorismo
juvenil idéias a chupeta quais várias
áreas e por ter um final o estrogênio
preciso informar programar isto além dos
controles de lembrei a palavra
informática informação automática
a nossa sociedade à informação
como é que nós comunicamos chega a todas
as áreas
vamos a um exemplo
ok isso na consciência da rfm plasma
sanguíneo que o diretor hoje mas este
estudo destinou este nunca mais curamos
nada está fora e só voltar 23 10 está
foco em gente tem não apenas na casa dos
30 anos e 81 de cima ou seja ele não tem
tempo pra nada não preciso ler você tem
um problema vão avançar netbooks que
pesquisam e encontrou assunção
não vou usar o exemplo e hoje segue e
hoje estaria cá os move em direção à
meta que não seria um mero visionário
baía farta sabe que ela o trabalho de
batedor não sabe o que é perder no
domingo 25
isto cá dentro e as fotos também com o
dia com z problema e portanto como isso
quer dizer que nós temos um acesso à
informação amo muito fácil nesta questão
da google e do conhecimento e da
informação pensem na maneira como é que
a sociedade hoje ele é condenado de trás
estavam no computador
andré sai do controle que tu vê é para a
tua vista
hoje ao contrário este mês vamos vaiar
xingar semeiam viola só nos faz no
computador no youtube no facebook com
músicas e ligou para o pai que era
melhor eu já tô cansado nós pagamos em
informática e um do mesmo a maneira como
nós vivemos tem um grande papel na
sociedade na questão da produtividade
das empresas
eu tive das empresas que vocês olhem
como é que as empresas trabalham agora
infelizmente tem alguns maus exemplos de
organizações sai social e conhecimento
por exemplo num sítio em que o país vive
um processo que está cheio do país sem
página está procurando informação e
consultar informação na gestão da
informação a empresas que ainda não usam
informada da melhor maneira que eu dei
tem culpa se tempo
xx e pelos alunos encomendas da empresa
atualmente e não fiz nada isto e porque
eu ganhei todos os processos da empresa
com o sistema de filmagem que tem por
isso desde um pouco menos ativas como
serviço e não faz rigorosamente nada
então veio o tempo que o pai mantém
impune e estes automaticamente a quatro
anos antes de implementar eu estava em
média cinco horas por dia
agora eu gosto meia hora só paixão do
esporte por isso é isso que está na
comunicação
nós temos agora o facebook em comunicado
no facebook para ter sucesso nos
projetos cria um grupo fácil - várias
pessoas na faculdade para terminar o
projeto porque existe sempre existe
porque o colega que não quer trabalhar
que tem está sendo pensado numa ontem à
noite era muito fácil no facebook zero
paula é testar esta parte não avança e
comunicação mais uma vez filme a grande
evolução da sociedade para que nós
chegássemos a capacidade que os a
informação que nós temos índices
produtivos e das também tem o tempo tem
outra questão que chegava chega matérias
e imagens do que aconteceu na madeira
duas pás fez isso com os meus amigos
todos as páginas de empresas e
organizações em 78 anos eu estava estar
hoje em dia já estava o pai e olha esta
é a foto está fazendo agora estou com a
nossa também a questão da produtividade
e da convicção já há uns anos dono dos
meus 8 e outro com a expulsão da
explosão da internet do doca 1
campinense agora que nem espera produtos
revolucionários do as
os drones da amazônia e não se viram o
tópico do software do google que eu faço
no mundo las e basicamente três nós
passamos o jude hoje passou desde agora
tá valendo
working mas estava tão numeroso e meio e
nós estamos num andar e nós ficamos com
alguém e vemos um mundo olha para baixo
hoje um ataque em cima que tantas
pessoas
então o golo a ser basicamente pegar um
objeto não intrusivo com os nossos
óculos e aumentar a realidade não é só
na questão dos em mel os computadores
mas também criar objetos que se insiram
no nosso dia a dia
os drones os drones de compadrio falar
próximos processos de uma empresa um
processo do início ao fim será
automática
agora pegamos um time toma zona enviado
para as pessoas com drones do pagar ao
envio automático e então empresa
consegue escalar
nós tivemos problemas porque falava da
questão de não autorizar o guará em
outro tipo de bateria enviamos temos
sempre essa questão da identificação das
pessoas da sociedade em conseguir subir
segundo dias o tamanho o mote lançado há
pouco em pouco tempo as chamadas assim
não só aquela caixinha e microondas com
126 físico e um engenheiro informático
não tem 6 é uma pessoa está a lei contra
o legião é bobo aqui é não é normal na
nossa cola chá bar não trabalha ainda
para a esposa fazer um tempo em
part-time os caveiras e então cometeu 11
outro muito interessante neste último
ano com os trabalhos de projetos e os
guia leigo pai e sua mãe não voltou ao
ginásio
não paro nunca quer ser autônomo e o que
quer ser o eu é prender pessoas em e e
além da não ficção como ajudar ainda viu
a pesquisar e com um treino tático
ok vamos foram aprovadas sem incluir
como sempre penso que o filme custou lhe
gasolina até pro mar e ficar tempo que
faz 16 o resto foi tudo à tona a dominar
infecções de receita contribuiu com
cuidado de vida e não testou no ginásio
tamanho lá placar não se conhecem e e
estava em vigor até xixi e caiu
não vou gastar dinheiro em um outro
carro
caso não fique assim fazer ontem o casal
tentou marcar mas é uma maneira de nós
conselhos para poupar dinheiro nos seus
motores novos campos de idéias e etc
essas pequenas coisas nós nos
acostumamos história da nossa vida em
uns nas despesas
nuno tem que informar que está está a
entrar no facebook e um em mauá
nunca iguais e não sei quantos há tanta
coisa e eu simplesmente ignora esse é o
facebook
acho que as pessoas não devem passar
a fase tudo suas vidas como cá fora a
imagem de samples é uma condição de
ativo nas redes sociais também top line
o senhor crime é de 7 mas é como ele
iguala tudo em tudo maiores troca
informação e isso nem que temos esse
problema
falando agora em termos de história de
insights que existem por aí ian no
facebook num mundo à parte dos pais
aquele que não encontrou nem ano da
faculdade da primária que termina amanhã
mídia não estávamos muito entrosados do
facebook aproxima as pessoas e tem
também a história que estava previsto em
memória a curto prazo é um tabu neste
momento
ganhou a taça da copa de 2010
quem olha a galera já com 70 mi mat
saúde é interessante
essa é uma das opções para ver a escolha
própria e sei que pegou na chegada à
praia com a filha assassinada era pessoa
de negócios na internet
o director do país precisa sair do café
ae o time estava sem um site na internet
que os 8 de abril através da escola
sabendo de uma grande e forte consegue
ficar com essa cara
assim pude escolher o melhor que posso
deixar a história do futebol ronaldo
pode estrear já neste vídeo que é usar
um problema que estavam ações naquela
sociedade nossos sociais do concelho
resolver esse problema o conhecimento da
mensagem
nós temos neste momento encontrar
soluções idade que a internet não está
em nós temos o quanto podem ser
conhecimento coincidência mas vamos dar
o exemplo e teve um problema durante
dois anos e fazer umas certas coisas
giras foi truncado mas fiquei preocupado
com os médicos vão faltar em um caso que
os vizinhos e à procura da solução e
sobre mel sobre esse problema e fiquei
mais calma após os olhos viam e resolveu
ficar resolvido e isso em uma esquina um
tempo no dia 7 mas com o fato de
perceber o problema é muito mais calmo e
os dom
a autonomia para pensar a do tamanho
outro exemplo estava estava a tentar a
minha bicicleta porque é que têm uma
maior trunfo a faculdade e não sabia
como pintar oficial em mãos certeiras e
quando chegamos a tempo inteiro para dar
mais dinheiro mas parte não conseguia
pintar já falaram alguns temas que os
próprios num não sabiam portanto mais
uma vez o conhecimento tem muito valor e
nós não podemos sair da faculdade e
deixar de aprender informática tem
muitas ferramentas de muitas funções que
os primeiros a informação e do
conhecimento já tinha seu nome é nós
pensarmos que já sabemos tudo se não
aprender
eu gosto de ver de vídeo no youtube
pesquisa no meu e seu nome de uma pessoa
consegue falar sobre diversos temas
então é por isto que foi hoje informado
que quer ser informado como eu de óculos
e tem um ex-ator seus computadores não
vê como uma pessoa chata que fala tem os
que não percebem mas cobrando linguagem
de programação em receita
vejo como pessoa potássio no próximo
facebook o próximo jogo disse
obrigado